Well, the fans are filing in here at Smartless Arena and we're ready for a great game. I think that all the teams today are ready to go and there's a lot on the line here. So let's see how they do over here on an all new Smartless. LAS. Smart. LAS. Smart. LAS. Listen, I just want to say this, Jay, I haven't, because I haven't until now,
好，球迷们正在Smartless竞技场排队入场，我们已经准备好迎接一场精彩的比赛。我认为今天所有的球队都蓄势待发，而且有很多利益攸关。所以让我们看看他们在全新一期的 Smartless 上表现如何。LAS。Smart。LAS。Smart。LAS。听着，杰伊，我只是想说这个，我没有，因为我直到现在都没有，
I think it's so brave. Uh oh. For you to, with your eyewear to go Sally, Jesse, Rafael, because I love the look. I, for me, I love it's so brave for you to, with your eyewear, to go Sally, Jessie, Raphael, because I love the look. For me, I love it. Sally, Jessie would be a red. Yeah, this is a black. But those do look like the same shape. The same shape, yeah, they are the same shape.
我觉得这太勇敢了。哦，天哪。为了你，戴着这副眼镜，去走萨利、杰西、拉斐尔的风格，因为我太喜欢这个造型了。我，对劳资来说，我太喜欢了，你戴着这副眼镜，走萨利、杰西、拉斐尔的路线，因为我太喜欢这个造型了。对我来说，我太喜欢了。萨利、杰西会是红色的。对，这个是黑色的。但那些看起来确实是相同的形状。相同的形状，是的，它们是相同的形状。
Wait, am I usually wearing a different pair of glasses? Aren't they kind of the same? I don't know, but for some reason today... No, those look a little more... They're casting you in a different light. They're casting you in a different light. They're casting you in a different role. Well, maybe it's because I'm suffering deeply from COVID. No.
等等，我平时戴的眼镜不一样吗？它们不是差不多吗？我不知道，但不知道为什么今天……不，那些看起来更……它们把你衬托在不同的光线下。它们把你衬托在不同的光线下。它们把你安排在一个不同的角色里。好吧，也许是因为我正深受新冠的折磨。不。
Maybe that's what you're seeing, Will. You don't have it. Why don't you have a little bit more sympathy for me because I'm lousy with COVID? Do you really have it? Yeah, but I didn't cancel today. I'm going to fight through and I'm going to do a great session. Wait, do you feel like shit?
也许这就是你所看到的，威尔。你又没有中招。你怎么不对我多一点同情心呢，因为我感染新冠病得不轻？你真的中招了吗？对，但我今天没有取消行程。我要坚持下去，我要做好这场访谈。等等，你觉得像一坨屎吗？
No, I'm on day six. So I'm still testing positive but the symptoms are all but gone. I don't know if you can, I still sound a little kind of 1993 Sunday morning, you know, a little backed up, a little schnitzel. Yeah. So you've had to tough it out there at your house. You know, a little backed up, a little schnitzel. So you've had to tough it out there at your house. It's not that tough. I've been there. It's old house.
不，我已经是第六天了。所以我测出来依然是阳性，但症状基本上都消失了。我不知道你能不能听出来，我的声音听起来还是有点像1993年星期天早上的感觉，你知道的，有点鼻塞，有点像施尼itzel（炸肉排）。对。所以你得在家里咬牙挺过去。你知道，有点鼻塞，有点像施尼itzel。所以你得在家里咬牙挺过去。没那么难熬。我在那儿待过。那是老房子。
Old goose shack. I'm feeling goose shack. The goose shack. The goose. Remember he was a chronic masturbator apparently. Okay. Can I tell you, you want to hear a funny story? Sorry.
老鹅舍。我觉得自己像在鹅舍里。鹅舍。那只鹅。记住，他显然是个慢性手淫狂。好吧。我能告诉你吗，你想听一个有趣的故事？抱歉。
Let me just close the COVID loop for one second. And let me say thank you to all the geniuses that, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, uh, that, that, uh, that, uh, that, that, uh, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, that, apparently. Okay, can I tell you, you want to hear a funny story? Sorry, let me just close the COVID loop for one second. Okay, yeah, go ahead. And let me say thank you to all the geniuses
让我先把新冠这个话题暂且收尾一下。然后我要对所有那些天才表示感谢，他们，呃，他们，呃，他们，呃，他们，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，那个，呃，那个，呃，那个，那个，呃，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，显然。好吧，我能告诉你吗，你想听一个有趣的故事？抱歉，让我先把新冠这个话题收尾一下。好吧，是的，请说。然后我要对所有的天才们表示感谢
that developed this vaccine, because I could tell that this is, I've had a pretty minor thing, you know, but were it not for the vaccine, I could tell this would not just be a cold. This would be, there's a little engine in this thing that the vaccine neutralizes pretty well. So thank you to the smart folks in the world,
研发了这种疫苗，因为我能看出这是，我的症状挺轻的，你知道的，但若不是因为疫苗，我看得出来这绝不仅仅是一场感冒。这会是，这东西里面有个小引擎，疫苗把它中和得相当好。所以感谢世界上聪明的人们，
the scientists and whatnot. So. You're welcome. Well, yeah, from Sean and I, from the bottom of both of our hearts, you're welcome. And dark, cold hearts. So. What are we gonna say, Will?
科学家之类的人。不客气。好吧，是的，从肖恩和我两人心底的最深处，不用谢。还有我们那颗黑暗、冰冷的心。所以。我们要说什么，威尔？
So there's a, in this, where I'm, where I currently am, and let's just keep it anonymous, and dark, cold hearts. Where I currently am, and let's just keep it anonymous but there's a certain chain department store nearby here. One of the people on our crew, he tells me that there is a certain app on his phone that's used for mail hookups that the bathroom and changing room at this place has glorious holes. What's the address? What's the address?
所以有一个，在这个地方，我现在所在的这个地方，让我们保持匿名吧，还有我们那颗黑暗、冰冷的心。在我目前所在的地方，让我们保持匿名吧，但附近有一家连锁百货公司。我们剧组的一个人告诉我，他的手机上有一个用于约炮的特定应用，这个地方的浴室和更衣室有很棒的洞。地址是多少？地址是多少？
Wait, was there an S on the end of hole? Holes. Can we double back to the multiple holes? Because I got questions, but go ahead. For sure, and so as we're working on this show, I have worked it into virtually every aspect of hosting this thing. People talking about their Lego and their build
等等，洞的后面有s吗？洞（复数）。我们能倒回去谈谈那个有多个洞的地方吗？因为我有问题，不过你继续。当然，所以当我们制作这个节目时，我已经把它融入了主持这档节目的几乎方方面面。人们谈论他们的乐高和他们的积木
and this thing has a hole in it. I go, somebody did a cruise ship. I said, you know, the only cruising I do is in the men's department over at blah, blah, blah. And the contestants have no idea what I'm talking about. And all the crew are dying because everybody now knows about this. Wait, who told you this, a guy that I work with
而这个东西上面有个洞。我说，有人去坐游轮了。我说，你知道的，我唯一去过的“巡游（溜达）”是在某某某的男装部。而参赛选手们根本不知道我在说什么。所有的工作人员都笑得要死，因为现在每个人都知道这事了。等等，谁告诉你的，我合作的一个家伙
who's on one of these apps for hooking up with other dudes and he goes, guess what, you'll never believe, like less than a mile from here is a full hookup thing, glory, plural, holes at this place. And I said, why wouldn't it just be hookups? Why is it glory holes? Like is that a real thing? And he said, yes wouldn't it just be hook up, why is it glory holes? Like is that a real thing? And he said yes.
他在这些跟其他男人约炮的app上，他说，你猜怎么着，你绝对想不到，离这不到一英里远的地方有一个全套约炮的地方，有荣耀，复数，那个地方有洞。我说，为什么不直接叫约炮？为什么叫荣耀洞？这真的是个东西吗？他说，是的，为什么不直接叫约炮，为什么叫荣耀洞？这真的是个东西吗？他说是的。
That's like leftover from the 80s. I didn't know that existed anymore. So first of all, the general concept of the glory hole is you can go ahead and you can put yourself in there and see what you get kind of thing. Or is it for those? First of all, it depends on what side of it you're on. That's right.
那就像是80年代遗留产物。我不知道那玩意儿现在还存在。所以首先，荣耀洞的总体概念是你可以直接把自己塞进那个洞里，然后看看能得到什么之类的。或者它是给那些……首先，这取决于你站在它的哪一边。没错。
Well, I love that you guys, you can ask me. Well, Sean, have you ever been to a glory hole? No. But is the concept that you're too ashamed to have a face-to-face hookup and that you just wanna put it in the mystery box? To be honest, I don't understand because the mystery box,
好吧，我很喜欢你们俩，你们可以问我。好吧，肖恩，你以前去过荣耀洞吗？没有。但这个概念是不是因为你太害羞而不敢进行面对面的约炮，所以你只想把它塞进神秘盒子里？说实话，我不明白，因为神秘盒子，
you don't know what's on the other side. You don't know the age, the STD level of that person. Then that was my next question. If you have multiple holes, and so I'm imagining that they vary in girth, and so will that then tell you, A, where you sit in the whole scale of things, but also what you're hoping is on the other side. I don't know if it's ever revealed. I don't think it's ever revealed.
你不知道另一边是什么。你不知道那个人的年龄，性病传染程度。然后那是我的下一个问题。如果你有多个洞，所以我在想它们的尺寸大小各不相同，那么这是否会告诉你，A，你在整个排名中的位置，但也告诉你你希望另一边是什么。我不知道它是否会被揭晓。我觉得它永远不会被揭晓。
It never gets revealed. I think we're, are we crafting a new reality show? That like, there's a reveal on the other side of somebody? Will, aren't you just kind of, will you, why don't you? Oh, I wanna go over there so bad, yeah. Go over there with your iPhone and just photograph what these holes look like and maybe, what sort of language
它永远不会被揭晓。我想我们在，我们是在打造一个新的真人秀节目吗？就是另一边会有一个揭晓环节？威尔，你难道不是，你会不会？哦，我太想去那边看看了，真的。带着你的iPhone去那边，拍下这些洞长什么样，也许还有，
there is on the wall. And then we're gonna be like, we haven't heard from Will in two hours. And the other thing is that we drive by every morning, like 7 a.m. we drive by every day, there's like a line in, it's like the mayor, the local pastor, like all these people. They're all coming out of the shop.
墙上有什么样的语言。然后我们会变成这样：我们已经两个小时没听到威尔的消息了。另一件事是，我们每天早上开车路过，大概早上7点我们每天都开车路过，那里有一条队，就像市长、当地牧师一样，所有这些人。他们都从店里出来。
Right, and they're all in there. And then the manager of the place is like, man, we got a line backed up here every day, but we do not move a lot of product, it's strange. But everybody, it just seems to everybody's all filled up before they come in here and they leave, they're empty. Or then they go in the dressing room and I guess nothing fits.
对，他们全都在里面。然后那里的经理就说，天哪，我们这儿每天都排着长队，但我们其实没卖出多少产品，这很奇怪。但每个人，看起来每个人在进来之前都吃饱了，离开时，他们都是空的。或者然后他们走进更衣室，我猜什么都不合适。
We got the wrong product. None of our product is fitting anybody. That's hysterical. We haven't sold a shirt. Can you imagine my delight when he told me this? Yes. When he told me that this was going on? By the way, does he frequent this place himself? No, he hasn't gone. He hasn't gone. But that's what he says. All right, well you bring us back a video, would you?
我们拿错了产品。我们的产品根本不适合任何人。这太滑稽了。我们连一件衬衫都没卖出去。当他告诉我这个消息时，你能想象我有多高兴吗？是的。当他告诉我正在发生这种事时？顺便说一句，他自己经常去那个地方吗？不，他没去过。他没去过。但他是这么说的。好吧，那你给我们带个视频回来，好吗？
I will. I'll keep you guys posted. Sorry. Anyway. And then send it to me as well. Alright, so this is a perfect segue into our guest. I can best describe our guest today as that guy from that thing. But truly, he's in everything you may know him from SNL, which doesn't narrow it down much. Although he's credited for co-creating Bill Hader's iconic character of Stefan. He's got not one, but three Netflix comedy specials.
我会的。我会随时向你们通报最新情况。抱歉。不管怎样。然后也发给我一份。好吧，所以这是一个完美的过渡，引入我们的嘉宾。我能对我们今天的嘉宾做出的最好描述就是“那个演过那个东西的家伙”。但说真的，他无处不在，你可能在《周六夜后秀》(SNL) 中认识他，但这并不能缩小太多范围。尽管他因联合创作了比尔·哈德 (Bill Hader) 的标志性角色斯特凡 (Stefan) 而受到赞誉。他不仅有一个，而是三个网飞 (Netflix) 喜剧特辑。
He stars as a chipmunk in Chip and Dale Rescue Rangers on Disney+. Boy does he make me laugh. It's Mr. John Mulaney. John Mulaney has found me. Hey. John, what do you have to say about the whole glory, whole thing before we wrap that up?
他在迪士尼+的《松鼠大作战》中饰演一只花栗鼠。天哪，他把我逗得哈哈大笑。他就是约翰·木兰尼先生。约翰·木兰尼找到我了。嘿。约翰，在我们结束这个话题之前，你对整个荣耀洞事件有什么想说的吗？
Is it drywall? Great question. Because I always thought it was the wall of a bathroom stall, which would be metal. Metal, right. Yeah, no, that's a separator. That's for wide stance folks. It would have to be drywall, yeah, or plywood.
是干墙吗？好问题。因为我一直以为它是浴室隔间的墙，那应该是金属的。金属，对吧。对，不，那是隔板。那是给站姿较宽的人准备的。那一定得是干墙，对，或者胶合板。
Or plywood. That's scarier. I've gotta go check it out. I mean, obviously I'm just obsessed with knowing the answer to all of this. Sure. I just wanna know what's written around it. You know, like, usually somebody's really kinda,
或者胶合板。那就更吓人了。我得去检查一下。我的意思是，很显然我只是对知道这一切的答案着迷。当然。我只想知道它周围写了什么。你知道的，就像，通常有人真的有点，
really running their mouth there when they write shit on a separator, right? Between a stall. On a separator, but you think maybe there'd be more grace and dignity to the glory hole, where it's like, there's no need to write crude things. Some sort of encouraging line, you know. The act itself is already.
当他们在隔板上写屎的时候，他们真的在喋喋不休，对吧？在隔板上，但你觉得荣耀洞可能会更有风度和尊严，就是那种，没有必要写粗俗的东西。某种鼓舞人心的台词，你知道的。这种行为本身就已经。
No, because it's about love. Yeah, and this is, it's all love, and we're gonna move through it with love. Maybe it's a Washington Post thing. Truth dies in the darkness, go ahead and enter, something like that. Yeah, you don't need all the arrows in the innuendo and the little limericks, which are in poor taste.
不，因为这是关于爱的。是的，这是，这一切都是爱，我们要带着爱度过它。也许这是《华盛顿邮报》的风格。真理死于黑暗，请进，诸如此类。是的，你不需要所有的箭头和双关语以及那些品味低劣的小打油诗。
Yeah, let's not be childish. We all know why we're here. It's a helmet on a helmet. Do you think that there's like some ink hair, you know, like some drawing of some hair and stuff like that? Or is it just like a big smiley face? I'm sorry, what? Okay.
对，我们别那么幼稚。我们都知道我们为什么来这里。这叫头盔套头盔。你觉得会不会有什么墨水画的头发，你知道的，比如画一些头发之类的东西？还是就只有一个巨大的笑脸？对不起，什么？好吧。
I could see if they have those screens you sometimes see in elevators that give you like the news, you know? They give you like limited financial and entertainment news. In case you've got stamina. Yeah, if you're standing there for a while, you wanna know. What if it says something, like something inspiring,
我能理解如果它们有那种你在电梯里有时会看到的屏幕，给你播报新闻，你知道的？它们给你提供有限的财经和娱乐新闻。万一你有体力的话。对，如果你在那儿站一会儿，你想了解一下。如果上面写着某种东西，比如鼓舞人心的话，
like you know when the football players run through it, like Notre Dame and there's something over the door, if there's just something real inspiring over it. What would get you charged up, Will? What would you wanna slap? Like go, go, go? You know, I don't know, Like, you know, go forth. Go get them?
就像你知道当橄榄球运动员跑过它时，比如圣母大学，门上方总会有些东西，如果门上方真的有些真正鼓舞人心的话语。什么能让你兴奋起来，威尔？你最想拍什么？比如冲、冲、冲？你知道，我不知道，就像，你知道，勇往直前。去拿下来？
Go get them. Go get them. You know, go bravely into the void or something. You know what I mean? Let me tell you something. This is not the way we started our session with David Rebnik. Okay? I can assure you that. I know. Mr. Mulaney's step...
去拿下来。去拿下来。你知道，勇敢地走向虚无什么的。你知道我的意思吗？我告诉你们一件事。这不是我们跟大卫·雷布尼克开始访谈的方式。对吧？我可以向你们保证。我知道。木兰尼先生的台阶……
It is how you started with Vivek Murthy, I think you believe. It's almost the exact same banter, which is a let down. It's a major let down. But that was more about the dangers of a glory hole. I know, because he's got to be that guy. He has to. Mr. Mulaney, thank you for being here today. I'm very, very flattered to be here.
我想你相信，这确实是你跟维韦克·穆尔蒂开始的方式。这几乎是完全相同的玩笑，这真让人失望。这是一个重大的打击。但那更多的是关于荣耀洞的危险。我知道，因为他必须是那种人。他必须是。木兰尼先生，谢谢你今天来到这里。我很荣幸能来到这里。
I've listened to, I think, almost every episode of the show. No, don't buy it. Well, will you listen to your own? Um, Absolutely. Yeah. All right good. No, John Mulaney I I'm such a and I think we all are such big fans Your last Saturday Night Live was so they all they're all great. But that last one was so fucking funny So your monologue was genius. I was like it was so funny How do you find such comfort, such comfort and such ease?
我听了这个节目的，我想，几乎每一集。不，别信。好吧，你会听你自己的吗？嗯，当然。是的。好吧，很好。不，约翰·木兰尼，我真是个，我想我们所有人都是你的超级粉丝。你上一次的《周六夜后秀》简直太，他们都很棒。但最后那场太TM搞笑了。所以你的独白是个天才之作。我当时觉得，太搞笑了。你是如何在其中找到如此舒适、如此自如和如此轻松的状态的？
Is it because you've been there so long? I think it is like home, right? It is a little bit like, yeah, it's like going back to school in a way, because you fall right back into the same, like fall back into the same insecurities and securities. And in terms of doing the monologue, it's so scary and it's so many people that it's laughable.
是因为你在那儿待了太久吗？我想这就像家一样，对吧？这确实有点像，是的，这在某种程度上就像重返学校，因为你会瞬间重新陷入那种，就像重新陷入同样的自卑与自信中。就做独白而言，这太吓人了，而且现场有那么多人，简直可笑。
I think I get relaxed because if something went wrong, it would go so wrong. And there'd be no way around, no one could talk me down and go, it's okay that you accidentally. And you can't blame anyone else because you're writing your own monologue, right? Yes, and it's you right into the,
我想我之所以能放松下来，是因为如果出了什么差错，那就会错得离谱。而且将无可挽回，没有人能劝导我说，你刚才不小心……这没关系。而且你不能责怪其他人，因为你自己写独白，对吧？是的，而且你直接对着，
not right into the lens, but basically. Basically into the lens. Malini, so you first got hired at SNL as a writer. Yes. Correct. Yep, but, Will, sorry to interrupt. Yeah, just interrupt, Sean. Go ahead and just, yeah. So then, so they just don't.
不是直接对着镜头，但基本上是。基本上就是对着镜头。木兰尼，所以你最初是以编剧身份被SNL录用的。是的。没错。对，但是，威尔，抱歉打断一下。对，尽管打断，肖恩。去吧，直接，对。所以，然后，所以他们不。
You know, let me say something. Let me say something. Good, good, good. You're right, I was hired as a writer. There you go, okay. Fucking. Sean, and then you. So wait, listen, Sean. Wait, Sean, we haven't moved on yet.
你知道，我来说点事。我来说点事。好，好，好。你说得对，我是作为编剧被录用的。就是这样，好吧。他妈的。肖恩，然后你。所以等等，听着，肖恩。等等，肖恩，我们还没翻篇呢。
To Will's point, what I wanted to interrupt. Wait, Sean. Wait, this has gotta be a great question. Hold on, everybody. Get it, Sean. No, I was gonna say, before SNL, you were discovered from the Conan, from Late Night with Conan, is that true?
顺着威尔的话，我想打断一下。等等，肖恩。等等，这一定是个好问题。等等，大家。说吧，肖恩。不，我是想说，在SNL之前，你是从柯南那儿被发掘出来的，从《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》，是真的吗？
And how did that go down? Like somebody, who saw you on that and what was that like? The talent department at SNL saw me on Conan. What's a talent department at SNL? What does that mean? It's the most, it's just a room of the most talented people in the world. Got it. We call them the talent.
那是怎么回事？就像有人，谁看到了你在那上面的表现，那是什么感觉？SNL的人才部门在柯南的节目上看到了我。什么是SNL的人才部门？那是什么意思？那是最多，那只是由世界上最具才华的人组成的一个房间。明白了。我们称他们为人才。
Let me see. But you know, also they saw me on Conan O'Brien, but I was doing Ascat monologues that same summer. And I, with, when Amy and Seth were doing Ascat a lot. So Amy Poehler, Seth Meyers were doing Ascat, which is an improv thing at Upright Citizens Brigade. So which is at 20, which at that time was at 26 and eighth under Gristides. Yeah.
让我想想。但你知道的，他们也在柯南·奥布莱恩的节目上看到了我，但那个夏天我也在做Ascat独白。我和，当时艾米和塞思经常做Ascat。所以艾米·波勒、塞思·迈尔斯在做Ascat，这是一个在Upright Citizens Brigade（正义公民剧团）的即兴表演项目。所以它在20号，当时在26街和第八大道交界处，Gristides下面。对。
And they might have, you know, I haven't, I think they kind of floated my name there as well. That seems familiar. Yeah. Because I knew some folks that were working there. And the desire was to be a writer or performer or both? No, I auditioned as a performer, but it's so, I don't know, there's so much,
而且他们可能，你知道，我没有，我想他们大概也在那里顺便提到了我的名字。听起来很熟。 yeah。因为我认识一些在那里工作的人。当时的愿望是成为一名编剧、表演者还是两者兼顾？不，我作为表演者去试镜的，但这太，我不知道，两者之间有太多，
it's so fluid between the two. So you're doing monologues at Ascot. How did you know Amy and Seth to do that? Like, you weren't on a tea improv team at UCB or anything? No, I'd been an intern at UCB, and I was taking classes there. When I first moved to New York in 2004, I was taking classes there and I was an intern there,
两者之间的界限非常模糊。所以你在Ascat做独白。你是怎么认识艾米和塞思来做这个的？就像，你又不是UCB的即兴表演团队成员什么的？不，我曾是UCB的实习生，我在那里上过课。2004年我刚搬到纽约时，我在那里上课，我是那里的实习生，
which meant I was taping garbage bags to the ceiling so that McDonald's water could leak down into the theater without splashing on the good folks. Did you start at 26 and 8th at that theater? Yeah, I started at 26 and 8th. I'd been to the first theater a couple times in college. And this was the second-less fire hazard of the theaters. And I... Yeah, so I was an intern.
这意味着我要把垃圾袋用胶带贴在天花板上，这样麦当劳的天花板漏水就能流进剧场里，而不会溅到好心观众身上。你是在26街和第八大道的那个剧场开始的吗？对，我从26街和第八大道开始的。我在上大学时去过第一个剧场几次。这是消防隐患相对第二小的剧场。我……是的，所以我当时是个实习生。
I was a janitor there. A janitor. On Saturday nights for, let's see, Respecto? Were they that night? Respecto Montalban. Respecto Montalban. What was that? For a while, the NYU Hammer Cats had a slot there.
我是那里的清洁工。清洁工。在周六晚上，让我们看看，Respecto？他们是那天晚上吗？Respecto Montalban。Respecto Montalban。那是什么？有一段时间，纽约大学锤子猫（NYU Hammer Cats）在那里有一个档期。
These are all improv teams. OK, got it. And I would watch them as I taped the garbage bags to the ceiling, because water was actively leaking. Wait, Malaney, remind our audience who is in respecto. Let's see, Rob Hubel, Owen Burke, and the rest. And all of them were in it. Willie, didn't you, I did a monologue, didn't I, at Ask Cat?
这些都是即兴表演团队。好吧，明白了。我一边把垃圾袋用胶带贴在天花板上，一边看着他们，因为当时水在哗啦啦地漏。等等，木兰尼，提醒一下我们的观众，Respecto里都有谁？让我想想，罗布·许贝尔、欧文·伯克，还有其他人。他们都在里面。威利，你难道没有，我做过独白，对吧，在Ask Cat？
You sure did, a couple times. Remind me how that, I just remember that. You had the sniffles that night, I remember. Did I really? You had the Saturday night sniffles, I think. Yeah, it was Sunday. Was I still enjoying? I don't know.
你当然做过，好几次。提醒我那是怎么回事，我只记得那个。那天晚上你流鼻涕了，我记得。我真的吗？我想你当时有周六晚上的流鼻涕症。对，那是星期天。我当时还在享受吗？我不知道。
But I remember it being very nerve wracking. Yeah, you did it a couple times at 26 and 8. Now, how did that go, remind me? I guess I was in a blackout or other things. It's a Herald. We'll have Mulaney remind you how it goes. John? Yeah? So you stand there and then you, don't you get sent like one word from the audience and then you gotta do a whole literally,
但我记得当时非常伤脑筋。对，你在26街和第八大道做过好几次。那么，进展得怎么样，提醒我一下？我想我当时处于断片状态或者其他情况。这是一个先驱节目。我们会让木兰尼提醒你它是怎么进行的。约翰？怎么？所以你站在那里，然后你，观众不是会给你一个词，然后你必须字面意思上做一整套，
just do a, improvise a whole monologue about that one word. Liquorish. You're scented in that they say it. You ask, yes. But you get, people yell out multiple words and I would say you pick the one closest to something you might have anything to say about.
就做一整套，即兴表演一个关于那个词的完整独白？甘草。他们说出来，你就把它送出去了。你问，是的。但你会得到，人们会大喊好几个词，我会说你挑一个最接近你可能有点话要说的词。
And then you just freestyle a story, but it has to last like five or 10 minutes, right? I think it's- Five minutes, and it's supposed to be true? Yes. Oh really? It's supposed to be a true story, yeah. Why, do you make your shit up?
然后你就即兴发挥一个故事，但它必须持续大约五分钟或十分钟，对吧？我认为是——五分钟，而且应该是一个真实的故事？是的。哦真的吗？它应该是一个真实的故事，对吧？怎么，你是在胡编乱造吗？
I don't, I don't remember. I honestly don't, how long ago was that? Wasn't that like 20 years ago? That was like, that was like 2003. I mean, would it be fair to say, why, did you make your shit up? I don't remember, I honestly don't, how long ago was that, wasn't it like 20 years ago? That was like 2003. I mean, would it be fair to say, Will, that it could be a full story with an arc, but almost, if you just gave details of anything, even if you just walked us through a procedure.
我没有，我不记得了。老实说我记不清了，那是多久以前的事了？那不是大约20年前吗？那就像是，那就像是2003年。我的意思是，这样说公平吗，威尔，那可能是一个有起承转合的完整故事，但几乎，如果你只是给出任何事情的细节，即使你只是带我们过一遍某个流程。
Yeah, yeah, I would never, once you do it more and more, because really what you're there to do is you're in service of the improvisers who are standing on the stage behind you, and you're trying to give them as many ideas to inspire them to create sketches, improvise sketches based on that. So, so, so, not really, not really.
对，对，我绝不会，当你做得越来越多的时候，因为你真正去那里的目的是为了服务于站在你身后舞台上的即兴表演者，你试图给他们尽可能多的灵感，来激发他们创作小品，根据这个即兴创作小品。所以，所以，所以，其实不是，其实不是。
Sean, what is with you today? Fucking, I know you're the star of Goodnight Oscar, but here there are other people, okay? So maybe in Chicago, armed with your fucking stellar reviews, you can just bust your way through shit. But here, there are other people. Anyway, John, so sorry. But that was the thing, right, John?
肖恩，你今天到底怎么了？他妈的，我知道你是《晚安，奥斯卡》的主演，但这里还有其他人，好吧？所以也许在芝加哥，凭借你那令人赞叹的星级评论，你可以强行闯过这些狗屁倒灶的事。但在这里，还有其他人。不管怎样，约翰，太对不起了。但事情就是这样，对吧，约翰？
You're just trying to give them ideas? Yeah, you're just trying to give texture and details. I mean, they're not gonna perform your story front to back. Right, and your story doesn't, what's it's a, yeah, front to back, that is the way to do it, right? Sean, do you have something you wanna say, Sean? My story's pretty good for my ass cap.
你只是想给他们提供灵感？是的，你只是想提供质感和细节。我的意思是，他们不会从头到尾表演你的故事。对，而且你的故事不，是什么，耶，从头到尾，这才是正确的做法，对吧？肖恩，你有什么想说的吗，肖恩？我的故事对于我的阿斯卡特（ascat）来说相当不错。
Here we go. It's really short. So Armani, the Armani, Giorgio Armani invited me, this is so long ago, invited me to Italy. We don't need the Armani, okay? Yeah, the Armani. N. Armani. Yeah. Somebody in the extended family.
我们来了。它真的很短。所以阿玛尼，那个阿玛尼，乔治·阿玛尼邀请我，这已经是好久以前的事了，邀请我去意大利。我们不需要阿玛尼，好吗？对，那个阿玛尼。N. 阿玛尼。是的。大家庭里的某个人。
Like the puppy. Do you see how funny this is? So we go to, he invited me to go to some fashion show in Milan. So I go there. Who? Who did? Giorgio Armani. At the real Giorgio Armani. At the real Giorgio Armani. At the original.
就像那只小狗。你看到这有多好笑了吗？所以我们去，他邀请我去米兰参加某个时装秀。所以我去了。谁？谁邀请的？乔治·阿玛尼。真正的乔治·阿玛尼。真正的乔治·阿玛尼。原版的。
At the original. Not to be confused with George Armani, who lives in the North Valley here. Go ahead. So I go there, I watch the thing, and then he invites, there's this party at his house afterwards, and so I get one of the guys that works there.
原版的。不要跟住在北山谷的乔治·阿玛尼混淆了。请继续。所以我去了，我看了那场秀，然后他邀请，活动结束后他家里有个派对，所以我找到了一个在那儿工作的小伙子。
How is this related to Ascath? This is the story I told for Ascats. Well no, it was a gathering. Ascats is a gathering of people and it sounds like this is too. Wait, so you told the story of going to Armani's house? Yes, and then I went to the house and I grabbed the guy who worked at the party
这跟Ascath有什么关系？这是我在Ascats讲的故事。哦不，那是一个聚会。Ascats是一个人们聚集的地方，听起来这个也是。等等，所以你讲了去阿玛尼家里的故事？是的，然后我去了他家，我拉住了那个在派对上工作的小伙子，
and I said, I wanna see the rest of his house. He's like, he really doesn't allow that. I'm like, please, please, please. So I go up to his, he gets in this elevator, I go up to his, the bedroom floor, right? And I go into his closet, because I wanted to see what clothes he wore. And in his closet is all in a line,
我说，我想参观他家的其他地方。他说，他真的不允许那样做。我说，求求你，求求你，求求你。所以我走到他，他坐上了电梯，我去了他卧室的那一层，对吧？我走进了他的衣帽间，因为我想看看他穿什么衣服。在衣帽间里，全都是排成一行的，
like 50 Navy shirts and 50 pairs of jeans below it. All the exact same lined up. Exactly, and it's all Tommy Hilfiger? And it's all Tommy Hilfiger. Were you caught? It's all from the gap. I wasn't. I got high-tailed it out there because I thought I was gonna get shot or something. Did you steal anything? No, no, no, I didn't steal anything. Great story. And now a word from our sponsor. All right, back to the show.
大概有50件海军蓝衬衫，下面有50条牛仔裤。全都是一模一样的排成一排。完全一样，而且全都是Tommy Hilfiger（汤姆·赫费格）？而且全都是Tommy Hilfiger。你被抓了吗？全都是GAP（盖璞）的。我没有。我赶紧溜了，因为我以为我要被枪毙什么的。你偷东西了吗？没有，没有，没有，我什么都没偷。好故事。现在听一段赞助商广告。好了，回到节目。
Anyway, listen, John, so you're from Chicago. I didn't know you're from Chicago and you went, how long did you live here and you grew up here? Zero to 18. Yeah, I grew up in Lincoln Park. Wow, I didn't know that. Yeah, you're from Chicago. You grew up in the Burbs.
不管怎样，听着，约翰，所以你是芝加哥人。我不知道你是芝加哥人，你去了，你在这是住了多久，你是在这里长大的吗？0到18岁。对，我在林肯公园长大的。哇，我不知道那件事。对，你是芝加哥人。你在郊区长大的。
Yeah. Sean's in Chicago right now. I know. I can tell from his hat and the view and the fact that I know he's there. So I've always wondered what that so listener Sean has on a hat with the four stars and the blue stripe across the top and a blue stripe across the bottom. That's a Chicago flag or an Illinois flag. So the city of Chicago has its own flag.
对。肖恩现在就在芝加哥。我知道。我从他的帽子、风景以及我知道他在那里的事实就能看出来。所以我一直很好奇，听众肖恩戴着一顶帽子，上面有四颗星，顶部有一条蓝色条纹，底部也有一条蓝色条纹。那是芝加哥市旗还是伊利诺伊州旗？所以芝加哥市有它自己的市旗。
Is that the only city? LA doesn't have a city flag does it? I'm sure it does. I'm sure it does. Guaranteed it does, yeah. Huh? I'm sure it does. I'm doing a Google search, right? New York City does. Wait, wait, wait, Melinda, you'll be happy to know
那是唯一的城市吗？洛杉矶没有市旗吧？我确信它有。我确信它有。向你保证它有，对。啊？我确信它有。我在用谷歌搜索，对吧？纽约市有。等等，等等，木兰尼，你会高兴地知道，
that when we were in Chicago doing our shows live, that Sean's generous friend came by and brought us Chicago hats. 20 different Chicago hats. Like literally 20. Steve Horvath, yeah. Steve Horvath, very kind of him. But I was like, how would we need to know?
当我们在芝加哥进行现场演出时，肖恩慷慨的朋友顺道给我们带来了芝加哥帽子。20顶不同的芝加哥帽子。字面意思上的20顶。史蒂夫·霍瓦特，是的。史蒂夫·霍瓦特，他太好了。但我就想，我们怎么会需要知道呢？
It was very generous. Sounds like it was a lot. It was a lot. I said I used too many hats. Well, the way you're describing it, it's not, I'm not getting just a generosity vibe. It's a lot of hats. Yeah, the amount was surprising. I will say this. And you probably had like carry-ons for the tour.
这太慷慨了。听起来数量不少。数量确实很多。我说我用不了那么多帽子。好吧，听你这么形容，这感觉不像是一种慷慨的氛围。这是太多帽子了。对，这个数量让人吃惊。我得这么说。你可能带了随身行李来应付巡演。
You didn't want... You had to now carry 20 hats and a laundry bag from the Four Seasons. Do you have merch at your shows, Jon? Yes! Thank you for mentioning that. That's short for merchandise. Sorry, Jon. What is your merchandise, Jon, I get to plug the merch I have a t-shirt that says I saw him just after he got out of rehab. That would be the bestseller right now No way. Yes, it says that and has the tour. So John so Malini you grew up you grew up in Chicago
你不想……你现在必须携带20顶帽子和来自四季酒店的洗衣袋。约翰，你的演出有周边商品吗？有！谢谢你提到这个。那是周边商品（merchandise）的简称。对不起，约翰。你的周边是什么，约翰，我得宣传一下我的周边我有件T恤上面写着“我看到他刚从戒毒所出来”。那现在绝对是畅销货。不可能。真的，上面写着这个，还有巡演信息。所以约翰，所以木兰尼你长大了，你在芝加哥长大。
When did you start? Did you start doing stand-up or did you start doing sketch? What was your trajectory? Like outside of a high school environment, I started doing, I did stand-up at a couple, not even open mics, just like weird variety nights at places like The Note and near Wicker Park. But that's ballsy though, to just start to do stand-up, were you scared? I had weirdly high self-esteem when it came to that.
你什么时候开始的？你是开始说脱口秀还是开始演小品？你的轨迹是怎样的？抛开高中环境不谈，我开始做，我在几个地方做过脱口秀，甚至不是开放麦，只是The Note和威克公园附近那些地方奇怪的杂耍之夜。但这就很有种了，直接开始说脱口秀，你不害怕吗？当涉及到这一点时，我有着奇怪的高自尊。
Not really about any other part of life, but I was like, yeah, no, I'm a headline. I'm gonna do this, it's gonna be great, people are gonna be talking about this. And then I did improv in college, I auditioned for the improv group my fourth day of college and the director was a young man named Nick Kroll. No way.
对生活中其他任何部分都没有，但我想，是的，不，我是个台柱子。我要做这个，这会很棒，人们会谈论这个。然后我在大学里演即兴喜剧，我在上大学第四天去参加了即兴喜剧团的试镜，导演是一个名叫尼克·克罗尔的年轻小伙子。不会吧。
Wow. He cast me, yeah, he was a senior, I was a freshman, and he cast me in the improv group. Very much changed my life. That's amazing. Wait, where was this, what college was this? This was Georgetown University in Washington, D.C. Wow.
哇。他选了我，对，他是大四学生，我是大一新生，他把我选进了即兴喜剧团。这极大地改变了我的生活。太棒了。等等，这是哪里，这是什么大学？这是位于华盛顿特区的乔治敦大学。哇。
Right, where you studied theology as well? Yeah, English and theology. Why? Oh, I thought. Wanna be a priest? No, Yeah, English and theology. Why? Oh, I thought- Wanna be a priest? No, I mainly studied Jewish theology. There were a couple very good Jewish studies professors at Georgetown and I just found it much more interesting
对，你还在那里学习了神学，对吧？是的，英语和神学。为什么？哦，我以为。想当牧师？不，是的，英语和神学。为什么？哦，我以为——想当牧师？不，我主要研究犹太神学。乔治敦大学有几位非常优秀的犹太研究教授，我只是觉得它更有趣，
theology because it's a lot more like, what the hell do we know? Yeah, what do we know from anything? Yeah, Catholics was a lot more like, this is the, you know, do this, and you'll spend this many days in fire, but then you can get out if someone prays for you. There were too many rules, too much structure.
神学因为更像是，我们到底知道个屁啊？是啊，我们对任何事有什么了解？是的，天主教则更像是，这就是，你知道的，这样做，你就会在火中度过多少多少天，但如果有人为你祈祷，你就能出来。规矩太多了，结构太严密了。
Judaism was a lot of like, who the hell are you to ask? You know, like, is there a God? Like, who the hell are you? Sounds like shorter chapters, which is probably smart. Excuse me? Who the hell are you to ask that? Why is there water? Get out of here.
犹太教则有很多像，你算老几敢来质问？你知道，就像，有上帝吗？就像，你算老几？听起来章节更短，这可能挺明智的。不好意思？你算老几敢问这个？这里怎么有水？滚开。
Get out of here. Mind your business. Now, were you a Weisenheimer in school when you were a little kid and that's where you thought maybe there might be a way to make a living here? I remember in third grade a teacher gave me an article like Xerox from Esquire. Like it wasn't for kids. It was like an, it was an article and it was about this guy Henry Beard who wrote for the Harvard Lampoon and the National Lampoon
滚开。少管闲事。现在，当你在学校还是个小屁孩时，你是个滑头吗？你觉得这是不是可以谋生的一条途径？我记得在三年级时，一个老师给我看了一篇文章，是从《绅士季刊》(Esquire) 上复印的。那不是给小孩子看的。它就像是一篇，它是一篇文章，讲的是一个叫亨利·比德的家伙，他为《哈佛讽刺家》和《国家讽刺作家》写作，
and the name of the article was the original smart ass white guy. And she slipped it to me, Miss Koal, and she said, you'd be into this guy and this type of thing. That's cool. And yeah, it was cool. But I don't recall being like a troublemaker. But you knew that you had skills you were making kids laugh that that felt good yeah and you wanted more. And I was kind of a writer performer in
那篇文章的名字叫做“原创聪明绝顶的白人”。她把它偷偷塞给我，科尔老师，她说，你会喜欢这个家伙和这种类型的。挺酷的。是的，挺酷的。但我不记得自己是个捣蛋鬼。但你知道你很有天赋，你逗得孩子们哈哈大笑，那感觉很好，对，而且你想要更多。而且我有点像个编剧兼表演者，
that I would tell more poorly behaved children what might be a funny thing to do. Right. What if someone threw that out the window right now? And they would take the bait and you would watch? Yeah that'd be pretty pretty What if someone threw that out the window right now? And they would take the bait and you would watch? Yeah, that'd be pretty crazy if someone just threw their potato battery out the window right now. Right. Can you imagine how that'd be crazy? I know you're pretty unstable. God, you would've been... You've got a lot going on at home. Maybe you'd be like a king for a day if you did that.
我会告诉那些表现更糟糕的孩子们，做什么可能是件搞笑的事。对。如果现在有人把那个扔出窗外会怎么样？他们就会上钩，然后你就在一旁看着？对，那会挺，挺——如果现在有人把他们的土豆电池扔出窗外会怎么样？对。你能想象那会有多疯狂吗？我知道你挺不稳定的。天哪，你以前……你家里有很多事。如果你那样做，也许你会当一天之王。
You'd be great in a cult. You'd be great if you worked in a cult. I think I'd be pretty susceptible. I don't have a lot of cult confidence. I don't know how... I don't know if I'd be the leader. I think I'd be a member. And it'd take me a while. It'd take me a while to see the light.
你在邪教里一定混得很好。如果你在邪教工作，你一定很厉害。我觉得我挺容易受影响的。我对邪教没有太多自信。我不知道怎么……我不知道我是不是能当领袖。我觉得我会是个成员。而且这会花我一点时间。我需要一段时间才能看到光明。
Are you saying there wasn't a lot of bad behavior when you were a little kid? Like, because I'm just going through... As soon as you said battery, I had this horrible memory of me and my friends like throwing batteries at like stuff. Like, and there's more detail to that. I remember, I remember we got caught tagging up a garage. Yeah, we were always, we were really-
你是说你小时候没有什么不良行为吗？因为我只是在经历……你一说电池，我就有一段可怕的我和朋友们拿电池砸东西的记忆。就像，里面还有更多细节。我记得，我记得我们因在一个车库乱涂乱画被抓了。对，我们总是，我们真的很——
You were in a tag crew? Yeah, and my tag- Was hat sideways? Tell me the hat was sideways. No. Just a little you we wrote we wrote we are the fuckers sure and did you spell fuckers all weird like no scary weird if you came to me it was just the declaration we are we are the fuckers of what what? Of what?
你们加入了一个涂鸦帮派？对，而且我的涂鸦——帽子是歪的吗？告诉我帽子是歪的。没有。只是稍微有点，我们写，我们写“我们是他妈的混蛋”，真的，而且你把“混蛋”拼得很奇怪吗？不，是可怕的那种怪，如果你来找我，那就只是一种宣告：我们是，我们是什么的混蛋？什么的？
Of everything, man. Of anything. Especially a garage door. You guys are hardcore. So you could have gotten trouble if you'd gotten caught. You could have gotten trouble for a few dozen things when you were a kid or not. Yeah, and I had a real... I didn't have a pyromania phase, but my good friend did.
什么都是，兄弟。什么都可以。尤其是车库门。你们真够硬核的。所以如果被抓到，你们会惹上麻烦的。你小时候可能会因为几十件事惹上麻烦，或者没有？对，我真的有……我没有狂热纵火的阶段，但我好朋友有。
And I would supervise. I kind of supervised that a little. You weren't mean to cats or anything, were you? Not at all, no. Not at all. Love was allergic to cats, so we had kind of agreed to disagree, relationship cats and I. But... Would you put like food coloring in beverages
而我会监督。我有点监督了那个过程。你没有对猫或者别的什么东西刻薄吧，对吧？完全没有，不。完全没有。爱对猫过敏，所以我和猫的关系算是求同存异吧。但是……你会不会把像食用饮料里加食用色素
and things like that, John? No, but we would do a lot of like, what could we put a bottle rocket in? What do you think, he was in a church group? He's studying theology and being a real hellcat. So I'm trying to- But no, but you're like the foreman of trouble. Like you just got everybody else creating trouble for you.
之类的事情，约翰？不，但我们会做很多类似的事情，比如，我们能把冲天炮塞进什么东西里？你觉得呢，他参加过教会团体吗？他学的是神学，还是个真正的地狱猫。所以我正试图——但不是，但你是麻烦的总工头。就像你让其他人为你制造麻烦。
The George Foreman of trouble? Yeah, you're like the foreman's grill of trouble. Yeah, I was. I was healthy, lean. Wait, so, um, wait, so, so, John, so you go to, you go to, uh, uh... Georgetown. Georgetown. And, uh, you're the guy running the, the, the improv team, group, whatever. Well, now hold on a second. I gotta stop you there.
麻烦界的乔治·福尔曼？对，你就像麻烦界的福尔曼烤盘。对，我以前是。我很健康，很精瘦。等等，所以，嗯，等等，所以，所以，约翰，所以你去了，你去了，呃……乔治敦大学。乔治敦。而且，呃，你就是那个运营即兴喜剧团队、小组什么的家伙。好吧，现在等一下。我得在那里打断你一下。
Uh, I see John's got a Zevia beverage in his hand. Oh! Now that is that it is a stevia based Soda and I think I can safely recommend every single flavor. Hang on John You're not getting any freebies out of this. You're a guest. I don't need my recurring Amazon. I have two Recurring Amazon orders that I one I don't know how to cancel and one I can't find. See, that's why I've never signed up for the automatic. What is the one you don't know how to cancel? It's so much cream soda, but I'm fine with it,
呃，我看到约翰手里拿着一瓶Zevia饮料。哦！那是一种基于甜味剂的苏打水，我想我可以放心推荐它的每一种口味。等一下，约翰。你在这可捞不到什么免费的好处。你是个嘉宾。我不需要我重复的亚马逊订单。我有两个重复的亚马逊订单，一个我不知道怎么取消，另一个我找不到。你看，这就是为什么我从不注册自动订购。你不知道怎么取消的是哪个？那是超级多的奶油苏打水，但我其实挺喜欢的，
but it's backing up. There's Baby Formula diapers and so much cream soda Zivia, and they're tall boys too, because I just. Oh, I do like that, the tall ones are nice. They can make tall ones, yeah. Now, that gets us into, you seem like a guy who watches what they put in their body.
但它堆积如山了。那里有婴儿配方奶粉、尿不湿和超级多的Zevia奶油苏打水，而且还是大号罐装的，因为我只。哦，我确实喜欢那个，大号的挺好的。他们能做大号的，对。现在，这就把我们引入了，你看起来像是个注意控制饮食的人。
We're gonna double back to Georgetown. I was sorry, are we back to the glory holes? Oh no. No. Yeah. We went all the way back. So, is there no sugar goes into that body, John? No, sugar goes into this body. Yeah.
我们要回过头去谈谈乔治敦大学。我很抱歉，我们又绕回荣耀洞了吗？哦，不。不。对。我们又绕回去了。所以，没有糖进入那个身体，约翰？不，有糖进入这个身体。对。
I am recently Sober and so I'm allowing myself a lot of Sugar in sugar and indulgences. Yeah, I'm trying to cut back but I haven't yet Today and I won't tomorrow watch out for the man with no vices. Let go ahead and keep one or two Yeah sugars just fine work. I quit smoking cigarettes in November too. Oh, but is that going? How's that showing off? Stop showing off.
我最近戒酒了，所以我允许自己摄入很多糖分和纵容。对，我正试图减少，但我还没做到。今天不会，明天也不会。小心那个没有恶习的人。好吧，留着一两个吧。对，吃点糖挺好的。我在11月也把抽香烟给戒了。哦，进展得怎么样？别炫耀了。
I went to a hypnotist. Yeah. He was a UCLA paranormal professor who now hypnotizes people in his garage in Santa Monica. Sounds safe. You see spaceships when he's done? I mean, honestly, none of this seems problematic to me. Keep going.
我去找了一个催眠师。对。他是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的超自然现象教授，现在在圣莫尼卡的自家车库里催眠别人。听起来很安全。他做完之后你能看到飞船吗？我的意思是，老实说，这些对我来说都没有问题。继续。
Remember how I said I'm susceptible to cults? Well, I go to this guy's garage. I've spent eight hours in the garage. So you're telling me the guy with the crystal ball, he moved his operation into the garage and now he's getting people off butts? Well, if he's so fake, how come he has some headshots thanking him for his work? So bad.
还记得我说过我很容易受邪教影响吗？好吧，我去了这家伙的车库。我在车库里呆了八个小时。所以你是说那个拿着水晶球的家伙，他把业务搬到了车库里，现在他正在帮人戒掉烟瘾？好吧，如果他是骗子，那为什么他有一些感谢他工作的签名照呢？太烂了。
Some. Yeah, some sun-faded headshots thanking him for getting them off cigarettes. Entertainers who I recognize vaguely. Wait, so did it work? I mean, are you craving cigarettes? No, it actually did work. I mean, I smoked from 13, age 13 to 39 and stopped in November after the second session. Cold turkey.
有些。对，有一些褪色的签名照，感谢他帮他们戒了烟。那些我隐约能认出来的艺人。等等，所以真的有用吗？我是说，你现在烟瘾犯吗？不，其实真的有用。我是说，我从13岁开始抽，从13岁抽到39岁，11月份在进行了第二次咨询后就戒了。直接彻底戒掉。
No weaning whatsoever. First hypnotism session, you get to keep smoking for that week, which is a big reason I did it, was that I love smoking. So, second session, walked out, never had another. Third session, I actually don't remember. I really did go somewhere else. That's nice.
完全没有循序渐进。第一次催眠咨询时，你那一周还可以继续抽烟，这也是我参与的主要原因，因为我太喜欢抽烟了。所以，第二次咨询结束走出来后，就再也没抽过。第三次咨询，其实我记不清了。我真的感觉自己去到了另一个地方。那挺好的。
That's great. So John Mulaney, I want to talk to you about, Marty Short is a good friend of mine, good friend of ours. The greatest. And I loved your sitcom called Mulaney with Marty. Really? Thank you. I did, I loved it. I watched every episode. Thank you. I did, I loved it. I watched every episode.
太棒了。所以约翰·木兰尼，我想跟你聊聊，马蒂·肖特是我的好朋友，也是我们的好朋友。最棒的朋友。我特别喜欢你和马蒂合作的那部情景喜剧《木兰尼》。真的吗？谢谢你。我是真的很喜欢。每一集我都看了。谢谢你。我是真的很喜欢。每一集我都看了。
Thank you very much. Malaney, I used to watch the, on the tap over at Radford Studios, I would see you guys rehearsing all the time. It was so fun. It was one of the most fun experiences making the show. He speaks so highly of you, just so you know. I love him very much.
非常感谢。木兰尼，我以前经常在拉德福德制片厂的磁带上，看着你们一直在排练。太有意思了。制作这部剧是我经历过最有趣的事情之一。他极力称赞过你，跟你说一声。我非常爱他。
Yeah, it's mutual. I want to see that, damn it. I apologize. 2014, it's mutual. I want to see that, damn it. I apologize. 2014, Fox. Until... From August to November of 2014. So it was a tight 13? I think they did air all 13.
对，彼此彼此。真想看看那个，该死。抱歉。2014年，彼此彼此。真想看看那个，该死。抱歉。2014年，福克斯。直到……从2014年8月到11月。所以总共精简的13集？我想他们确实播出了全部13集。
Our final episode aired against the SNL 40th, which I was working on. And we ended up losing to that, the ratings that night. That's like the, Will, didn't they air the very final episodes of REST Development against the winter Olympics? Opening of the Olympics. Opening ceremonies. They burned all four in a row,
我们的最后一集播出时，正好撞上了《周六夜现场》开播40周年特辑，当时我也在参与制作。结果那天晚上的收视率我们输给了他们。那就像是，威尔，他们不是把《发展受阻》的最后几集跟冬季奥运会撞期播出了吗？奥运会开幕式。奥运会开幕式。他们一口气把四集全烧了，
and they didn't tell anybody, they were like, get these off our feet. Salt Lake City. Was it? 2006. But Sean, was that sitcom? Sorry, get these off our face. Salt Lake City. Was it? But John, was that sitcom? Sorry, sorry Sean. No, that's okay. Was that something you always wanted to do
而且没告诉任何人，他们当时的心态就像是，赶紧把这烫手山芋扔了吧。盐湖城。是吗？2006年。但是肖恩，那部情景喜剧？抱歉，赶紧把这烫手山芋扔了吧。盐湖城。是吗？但是约翰，那部情景喜剧？抱歉，抱歉肖恩。不，没关系。那是你一直想做的事吗？
and you're passionate about it? I was, I was passionate about, I was and am passionate about Multicam. I really like it. You and me both. So do we. Yep, and I, I mean I grew up on them, but also I just find it...
而且你对此充满激情？我当时，我对多机位拍摄充满激情，过去是，现在也是。我真的很喜欢。你我一样。我们也一样。对，而且，我的意思是我是看着那些长大的，但我也觉得……
And maybe it's also the Saturday Night Live in me and the stand-up in me. I just like three to four cameras and yelling jokes to the back of the room. And an audience, a live audience. And a live audience, yeah. And the six-hour day. Oh my God. I mean, as the EP and writer and everything, I didn't have that. But watching Elliot Gould and Marty Short and Naseem Padrad leave at three, I just thought, oof, that's the life of King.
也许这也是我身上《周六夜现场》和单口喜剧的属性吧。我就是喜欢三到四个摄像机，然后冲着房间后方大喊笑话。还有观众，现场观众。还有现场观众，对。还有六小时的工作日。天哪。我的意思是，作为执行制片人、编剧兼各种职务，我可没有那种待遇。但看着埃利奥特·戈尔德、马蒂·肖特和纳西姆·帕德拉德在三点钟离开，我当时就想，哇，那才是人过的神仙日子。
Would you do another one? I would, yeah. Yeah? You should. You'd be very late. We need to crack that. I'm calling you after this session. It's... Who directed most of those episodes, do you remember? I just, when they're good, They're so great Andy Ackerman wonderful
你还会再拍一部吗？我会的，对。是吗？你应该拍。你会非常……我们得想办法搞定这个。我在这场访谈结束后就给你打电话。那是……你还记得大部分剧集是谁导演的吗？我只是觉得，当它们优秀的时候，真的是太棒了。安迪·阿克曼，太棒了。
Oh, yeah, Seinfeld. Yeah. Yeah, of course I'm felt many other great things and then let me ask you this because I've always wanted to know I've always wondered about like a Plus stand-up like yourself who do all these specials and your tour and you're constantly writing by the time we see Your special on Netflix or wherever it is, how many times have you tried out the material and how many rewrites do you go through before we see it? Or are we seeing stuff that you trusted or know will work from the moment you wrote it?
哦，对，《宋飞传》。对。对，当然还有《宋飞传》以及许多其他伟大的作品。然后我想问你这个，因为我一直很想知道，我一直很好奇，像你这样优秀的单口喜剧演员，做过这么多专场、巡演，而且一直在创作。当我们看到你在Netflix或其他地方的专场时，在你真正演给我们看之前，你把这些素材试演了多少次？经历了多少次重写？还是说我们看到的都是你从写下来的那一刻起，就深信不疑或知道一定能行的东西？
Oh, those seem like two questions. Yeah, it's a problem with Sean. So, yeah. Okay, the first part is, it depends on how much I toured before the special. Yeah. So I did that sitcom. Production was shut down in October. I went on the road the next week.
哦，听起来这是两个问题。对，这就是肖恩的问题所在。所以，对。好吧，第一部分是，这取决于我在专场前巡演了多少场。对。所以我做了那部情景喜剧。10月份制作叫停。第二周我就去巡演了。
And then I taped a special that May called The Comeback Kid for Netflix. That was a pretty short tour. The last special I did, there was about a year of touring before it. This one will be like... This one will be close to a year, maybe over. I'm on the road steadily right now. How do you like that road stuff, that touring stuff, that staying in a hotel every night? I love it.
然后在第二年五月，我为Netflix录制了一个名为《逆袭小子》的专场。那是一次相当短的巡演。我做的最后一个专场，在它之前大约有一年的巡演时间。这次的会像……这次会接近一年，甚至可能超过一年。我现在一直在路上巡演。你觉得那种在路上的生活，那种巡演的生活，每天住在酒店里怎么样？我很喜欢。
I like hotel living. I really like tour bus living. You take your own slippers with you when you go to all those hotels? I bring my own pillow, but I take their pillowcase. What does that mean? Jason doesn't like, doesn't Jason won't walk on the floors of a hotel.
我喜欢住酒店。我真的非常喜欢住巡演大巴。你去所有那些酒店时，都会自带拖鞋吗？我带自己的枕头，但用他们的枕套。这是什么意思？杰森不喜欢，杰森不在酒店的房间地板上走路。
He will not walk on the floors of a hotel without a barrier. And then. Do you put the remote in a Ziploc bag before you use it? I put it in a pot of boiling water. And then if it still works, we're on it. But if it doesn't work, then there's no TV. So you take the pillowcase...
他不做好防护措施的话，是绝对不会在酒店地板上走路的。然后。你用遥控器前会把它放进密封袋里吗？我把它放进一锅开水中。然后如果它还能用，我们就用它。但如果不能用了，那就没电视看。所以你拿了那个枕套……
Jason basically lives like Howard Hughes. He has, like, at all times, don't show him your fingernails. And he's got like 12 layers of Kleenex between himself and anything that he touches You're using the you're bringing your own pillow, but you're using their pillowcase because you want to make any watch this No, what happened? It's worse than that. I took one pillowcase from the first hotel on this tour. Where did it start? We started in Portland, Maine maybe. I took a pillowcase and it's still on. Because you like the thread count on that one. You're like, oh, we're gonna keep this.
杰森的生活方式基本上就像霍华德·休斯。他随时随地，别让他看你的指甲。而且他在自己和任何触碰的东西之间，隔着大约12层面巾纸。你用的是，你带了自己的枕头，但你用的是他们的枕套，因为你想让任何……看这个，不，怎么了？比那更糟。我拿了我这次巡演第一家酒店的一个枕套。从哪开始的？我们在缅因州波特兰开始的吧。我拿了一个枕套，现在还套着呢。因为你喜欢那个枕套的纱支密度。你当时想，哦，这个我们要留着。
I liked that it was long and my special foam pillow is longer than a regular pillow too. So it was cool. It was a nice fit. You sleep with the pillow between your knees? I got one of those at an As Seen On TV store at Foxwoods recently. Oh, it was like a body pillow.
我喜欢它比较长，而且我特制的记忆棉枕头也比普通枕头长。所以挺好的。尺寸很合适。你睡觉时把枕头夹在膝间吗？我最近在福克斯伍兹的一家“电视购物”实体店买了一个。哦，那就像是一个身体抱枕。
No, it's like a little, it looks like a yoga block except it has a skate ramp in it. And you put it right between those knees. And if you guys are at anyone near the As Seen on TV store at the mall in Foxwoods, the casino, they have them there. And again, that's at the Foxwoods casino, they're at Outlet Malls, and there's an As Seat on TV. Not too quickly, Sean's a slow writer,
不，它就像个小东西，看起来像个瑜伽砖，只不过中间有个滑板坡道。你就把它直接放在两膝之间。如果你们有谁在福克斯伍兹商场里的“电视购物”店附近，那个赌场，他们那有卖。再说一次，那是在福克斯伍兹赌场，它们在奥特莱斯购物中心，有一家“电视购物”店。别太快，肖恩是个慢笔，
so not too fast. Wait a second, is there really a store called As Seat on TV? Oh yeah, you've never been in one? You've never seen that? Come on. Oh, it's the greatest. Truly. It looks like a storage unit.
所以别太快。等一下，真的有一家叫“电视购物”的店吗？哦，对，你从来没进去过吗？你从来没见过？拜托。哦，那是最棒的。真的。它看起来就像一个自助仓储间。
Can I ask you what they sell in there? I mean, the one thing I was really intrigued by this time was something called Battery Daddy, which was, it looked like a, Tell me slow. It looked like a seedy tower, looked like a compact disc tower for batteries. It was a big, it was almost like a pyramid
我能问问他们里面卖什么吗？我的意思是，我这次真正感兴趣的一样东西叫做“电池老爹”，它看起来像一个，说慢点。它看起来像一个可疑的塔，看起来像一个电池的激光唱片塔。它是一个大塔，几乎像一个金字塔，
where all your sizes of batteries had different levels they could clip into. Could you use that? Definitely can't find the double A's when I need them. Now do you guys keep your batteries in the freezer by the way? Or am I just married to a crazy person? No, I don't think there's any science behind that. What are you, a photographer?
你所有型号的电池都可以在不同的层级上卡进去。你能用那个吗？我需要的时候绝对找不到5号电池。话说回来，你们平时把电池放在冰箱里吗？还是说我只是娶了一个疯子？不，我觉得那没有任何科学依据。你是什么，摄影师吗？
What's going on? I got one of those wedge pillows where you can slip your arm because my arm was bothering me for a while and I bought it from, I think, the back store, one of these things, it lacks the back. You actually put your hand, it looked like a mouse trap, and then I'd sleep on this thing anyway. What a catch, do you have a CPAP when you go to sleep too? Sean, do you, I don't, Sean, do you?
怎么回事？我买了一个那种楔形枕头，你可以把胳膊塞进去，因为我的胳膊疼了一段时间，我是从，我想是靠背店买的，就是那种没有靠背的东西。你实际上把手放进去，它看起来像个捕鼠器，然后我还是睡在这个东西上。真是个宝藏，你睡觉时也会用持续正压通气呼吸机吗？肖恩，你会吗，我不会，肖恩，你会吗？
My girlfriend, Olivia, we still have the pregnancy pillow, that horseshoe-shaped thing, and I slept in it the other day, and it is fantastic. It's like sleeping in a bumper bowling lane I woke up with something Sean Sean sleep Sean sleeps like in that position They tell you again when a plane's crashing like with this Grabbing his knees and they're just in case you got it wakes up real antsy
我女朋友奥利维亚，我们还留着那个孕妇枕，就是那个马蹄形的玩意儿，我前几天还枕着它睡了一觉，简直棒极了。就像睡在保龄球频道的缓冲道上一样，我醒来时带着某种……肖恩，肖恩睡觉，肖恩睡觉的姿势就像那种，他们再次告诉你飞机快坠毁时那种姿势，比如这样，双手抱膝，而且他们只是以防万一你懂的，他醒来时非常急躁。
Feel rested I never feel rested. I never feel rested. I saw an interview with Donny Osmond once where he was extolling the virtues of sleeping on the tray on a commercial flight. Sleep on the... No, that always makes me want to vomit. And did he say, make sure to drink 12 rums before you do it? I love you've got Donnie as a rum drinker. Bacardi, Bacardi. Yeah, not the Bacardi.
感觉休息好了吗？我从来没有休息好过。我从来没有休息好过。我曾经看过唐ny·奥斯蒙的一次采访，他在采访中大肆赞美在商业航班的小桌板上睡觉的好处。睡在……不，那总是让我想吐。他说过“确保在做这件事之前先喝12杯朗姆酒”吗？我喜欢你把唐尼当成朗姆酒酒鬼的设定。百加得，百加得。对，不是那个百加得。
Top shelf, top shelf. Wait, I want to get back to this long professional and personal relationship you have with the guy who let you into the improv group, which is Nick Kroll. The wonderful Nick Kroll. The wonderful Nick Kroll. My best friend, older brother, and everything. Mentor. Okay, well we got it now, we got it in writing
顶级货，顶级货。等等，我想回到你和那个带你加入即兴表演团的家伙之间长期的职业和个人关系，也就是尼克·克罗尔。了不起的尼克·克罗尔。了不起的尼克·克罗尔。我最好的朋友、老大哥以及一切。导师。好吧，现在我们知道了，有文字记录和录音为证，我们掌握了。
and in recording, we got it. Yeah, I know, that sounds good. I sound gracious, because he let me into the group and now just air it unedited. You've been paying him back ever since. But you guys, no it did, you guys are like brothers and you guys have worked together so much now over the last however many years
对，我知道，听起来不错。我显得很大度，因为他让我加入了这个团队，现在直接原封不动地播出去吧。你从那以后一直在回报他。但是你们，不，确实如此，你们就像兄弟一样，而且在过去的这些年里，自从你们认识以来，你们已经合作了这么多次，
since you've known each other. And is that like a thing that you guys consciously say or do you come back together every couple years or you go you do your own thing, you're like, hey let's go and do this or I don't know, how does it work? Well, let's see. For a while, we...
这就像是你们有意识地说好要这么做，还是说你们每隔几年就重新聚到一起，或者你们各自忙各自的，然后觉得，嘿，让我们去搞点这个，或者我不知道，这到底是怎么运作的？嗯，让我想想。有一段时间，我们……
That's a good question. We don't consciously plan, you know, let's work together in 18 months. We love working with each other, so he'd be my first thought for anyone to collaborate with. And then we have things that we've done consistently, like the theater show, Oh Hello, where we played these two guys, Gil and George, we did that in a variety of media and then did it as a play on Broadway.
这是个好问题。我们没有刻意计划，你知道的，要在18个月后合作。我们喜欢彼此合作，所以他是我想合作的任何人时的首选。然后我们有一些一直坚持在做的事情，比如戏剧演出《哦，你好》，我们在其中扮演两个角色，吉尔和乔治，我们在多种媒介中演出过，后来还在百老汇作为戏剧上演。
So like that's a thing where we will talk about revisiting those characters specifically. And then obviously I work with him on Big Mouth, on Netflix, but he's along with Andrew Goldberg and Mark and Jen Flackett. He's a creator, EP, so I'm not doing that with him, but I'm lucky enough to be on it. You're on it. Big Mouth for Tracy is a really funny, very popular animated show on Netflix.
所以，就像那类事情，我们会专门讨论重新审视这些角色。很显然，我和他在Netflix的《大嘴》中有过合作，不过他和安德鲁·戈德堡、马克以及詹·弗莱克特一起是创作者兼执行制片人，所以我并不是和他一起创作的，但我很幸运能参演其中。你在演。特蕾西参演的《大嘴》是Netflix上一部非常搞笑、非常受欢迎的动画片。
It's been on for five, four or five years. Tracy might even know that. Yeah, she might have. She's already moved on to human resources. She might. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, John, with all the things that you do and do well,
已经播出了五、四季或五季了。特蕾西可能甚至知道这一点。对，她可能知道。她已经转向人力资源部了。她可能知道。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。嘿，约翰，鉴于你做的一切事情以及你擅长的事情，
how do you decide what to do? Is it informed by some sort of five year plan that you do and do well, how do you decide what to do? Is it informed by some sort of five-year plan that you've got? No, never had a five-year plan. What about next week, next month? I'm a little, I remember a professor in college said, someone was like, someone said, just taking it one day at a time,
你究竟是如何决定该做什么的？这是否是由某种你制定的五年计划所决定的？不，从来没有过五年计划。那下星期，下个月呢？我有点……我记得大学里的一位教授说过，当时有人在说，有人说，凡事只要顺其自然、过好每一天，
and he said, that's great. Of of course Malaney lives minute to minute and like everyone laughed and I was really like yeah it was odd of him to call that out in the middle of a Jewish studies class but you have no no sort of North Star whether you whether you whether you get there or not at least it's giving you direction and helping. I love a knockout obituary and great speeches at the memorial service. But then I can't think, you know. You just want it to be glowing.
然后他说，那太棒了。当然啦，木兰尼就是按分钟过日子的，然后大家都笑了，我当时真的觉得，嗯，他在犹太研究课的中间特意指出这一点有点奇怪。但你没有任何类似“北极星”的东西吗？无论你最终能否达到目标，至少它能为你提供方向并给予帮助。我喜欢精彩的讣告和追悼会上的精彩演讲。但随后我就想不出来了，你知道的。你只是希望它是光芒四射的。
What do you want your tombstone to say? I've thought about this recently. If it could say anything. You know, I was walking around a cemetery in Connecticut where all the... Where you do. Where you do, and the graves are from like the 1700s. And back then, people would, I walked by a grave
你希望你的墓碑上写些什么？我最近一直在考虑这件事。如果可以写任何东西的话。你知道的，我曾在康涅狄格州的一座墓地里闲逛，那里所有的……正如你所做的那样。正如你所做的那样，那些坟墓可以追溯到1700年代左右。而在那个年代，人们会，我走过一座坟墓，
that said, handsome and brave. Dude, I'm so... It was like, a hero of the revolution, handsome and brave. I was like, I think I'm gonna take that. Yes, so this is what I thought. I was thinking the other, I was like, I think I'm gonna take that. Yes, so this is what I thought. I was walking around a cemetery a couple years ago one night, and not a big, just because it was a better, I get a better view inside the window of the,
上面写着：英俊而勇敢。伙计，我太……就像是，革命英雄，英俊而勇敢。我当时想，我想我要选这个。对，这就是我想的。我前几天晚上在一个墓地里闲逛，也不是很大，只是因为这样能更好地看进窗户里面，
doesn't matter, longer story, anyway. Obviously for a lawyer, I can't say why. Of course. But reading all the greatest stories, I was thinking like, I would want to put something like, he was a cool guy, that's it. Because then if I saw that, I'd be like, I would want to put something like, he was a cool guy. That's it. Because then if I saw that, I'd be like,
这不重要，说来话长，总之。显然对于律师来说，我不能说原因。当然。但读了所有最棒的故事后，我想，我想要写点类似“他是个酷家伙”的话，就这样。因为如果我看到那个，我会想：我想要写点类似“他是个酷家伙”的话，就这样。因为如果我看到那个，我会想：
who the fuck is that motherfucker? He was a cool guy? You know what I just read? I read that you can now get your body turned into compost and you can use it to plant a tree or something. It takes six months to turn it into compost. They just keep mixing the guts with dirt over and over again? You know, that's what happens when you just fucking bury a body.
那个王八蛋到底是谁？他是个酷家伙？你知道我刚刚读到了什么吗？我读到你现在可以把你的尸体变成堆肥，然后用它来种一棵树什么的。把尸体变成堆肥需要六个月的时间。他们只是把内脏和泥土一遍又一遍地混合吗？你知道，当你把一具尸体随便埋进土里时，发生的就是这个。
What do you think the body does in the ground by itself? It's a pickup truck worth of compost. So that just sounds like compost with a dead body in it. It doesn't sound like your body is doing anything. It does. That's a good point. Your gaseous, unembalmed body exploding in usable combos. I would love to see your search history though, Sean. No, I did. I looked at all...
你觉得尸体在地下自己会干什么？那可是一辆皮卡车分量的堆肥。所以听起来就像是里面有一具死尸的堆肥。听起来不像是你的尸体在发挥什么作用。确实是这样。说得好。你那充满了气体、未经防腐处理的尸体正在爆炸变成可用的堆肥。不过我真的很想看看你的搜索历史，肖恩。不，我看了所有的……
So would the FBI. Why did you buy all that lime? What's going on? I'd like... You know, I would like it said at my funeral or on my gravestone that I... Some of my flaws. Like he was late a lot. And people talked to him about it and he was still late. Are you still? Are you still late? I'm getting better at it. Do you know why you're late? I think... Well, one, Saturday Night Live completely destroyed my relationship with time.
联邦调查局也是这么想的。你为什么买那么多生石灰？怎么回事？我希望……你知道的，我希望在我的葬礼上或者在我的墓碑上写着我……我的一些缺点。比如他经常迟到。人们跟他谈过这事，但他还是迟到。你现在还迟到吗？你现在还迟到吗？我在努力改。你知道你为什么迟到吗？我想……好吧，第一，周六夜现场彻底摧毁了我对时间的观念。
In that meetings that were supposed to begin at 3pm wouldm. would begin at 5 p.m. or 6 p.m. with no explanation or apology. So after a couple years there, I would meet people 45 minutes late and not think I needed to say anything regarding where I'd been. Wow. Yeah.
因为原本应该在下午3点开始的会议，会拖到下午5点或6点开始，没有任何解释或道歉。所以在那里呆了几年之后，我去见别人时迟到了45分钟，也觉得不需要就自己去过哪里做任何解释。哇。对。
And then I think I'm better, I must think I'm better than everyone else. I mean, everyone else, I guess. What about having a kid now? Kid really puts you on a schedule, right? No, a kid put me on a schedule and I have made a big resolution to be on time, be where I said I'll be when I said I'll be there.
然后我想我比别人都强，我一定觉得自己比其他所有人都强。我是说，其他人，我猜。现在有了孩子感觉怎么样？孩子真的能让你过上有规律的生活，对吧？不，孩子让我过上了有规律的生活，我下定决心要守时，在答应出现的时间出现在答应出现的地点。
And I've actually been good about that. Like Sean, Sean said, I'm gonna be outside a fire station all day today. And obviously he is. I live in, yeah, in the middle of. What is your, what do you think you're best at being a dad? What do you think you're worst at being a dad? Oh.
而且我在这方面实际上一直做得不错。就像肖恩，肖恩说，我今天一整天都要待在消防局外面。显然他确实在那。我住在，对，在……你觉得你当爸爸最擅长的是什么？你觉得你当爸爸最不擅长的是什么？哦。
And I know we're early days, and we're just trying stuff out. Best at... Swaddle technique? I am a good swaddler. Yeah. I am a good swaddler. I am a good swaddler. I learned to swaddle somewhat from Ozarks. You give a brief swaddle tutorial if you recall.
我知道我们现在还在初期，还在尝试各种方法。最擅长的是……包裹婴儿的技术？我很擅长裹襁褓。对。我很擅长裹襁褓。我很擅长裹襁褓。我从《黑钱胜地》里多少学到了一点裹襁褓的技巧。如果你还记得的话，你可以做一个简短的裹襁褓教程吗？
And we were waiting on... You're not supposed to watch that. What was your favorite episode? I love the one where you're laundering all the money. Everyone's like, oh my God. People check out the department store, those glory holes, and they swaddle sometimes. They sure do.
我们当时在等待……你本来就不该看那个。你最喜欢哪一集？我喜欢你洗钱的那一集。每个人都觉得，天哪。人们去百货公司，去那些荣耀洞，有时他们也会裹襁褓。他们当然会。
Good at swaddling. I'm good at, I know when tummy time is over. Before Little Malcolm gives me that look, like Jesus, man, you're going to get me out of here? I know it's time, I know that big head is starting to get a little tired of bobbing up and down. I probably am worse at overthinking how to approach him as an adolescent,
我很擅长裹襁褓。我很擅长，我知道什么时候俯卧时间该结束了。在小马尔科姆给我那种眼神之前，就像是“天哪，老兄，你要把我从这儿弄出去吗”？我知道时间到了，我知道那个大脑袋开始对上下晃动有点厌倦了。我最不擅长的可能是在如何与他相处方面过度思考，特别是当他进入青春期时，
which I really don't need to worry about for the next few years, but I'm constantly running scenarios of what kind of parent I'll be when he's 11, 12, 13. The combo between being a dad versus being a best friend. Oh, just like, yeah, and will I be, in my mind I was like, I'm gonna be this semi-stern, I'm gonna be this, I'm gonna kind of be like my dad with him,
其实我在接下来的几年里根本不用担心这个，但我一直在脑海中模拟各种情景，想象当他11岁、12岁、13岁时我会成为什么样的父母。在当爸爸和当挚友之间寻找平衡。哦，就像，对，我会不会，在我的脑海里我想过，我会成为那种半严厉的人，我会成为这样的人，我会有点像我爸那样对待他，
and that's all falling apart in four months. I can't imagine ever criticizing anything this kid does or. But who do you, I mean you know Olivia. Don't worry, he'll come. No, I know. You know Olivia, Olivia knows you. Has it become clear who's gonna be the disciplinarian, who's gonna be the nurturer?
结果这一切在四个月内就全泡汤了。我无法想象自己会去批评这孩子的任何行为或者。但你觉得谁，我是说你了解奥利维亚。别担心，他会明白的。不，我知道。你了解奥利维亚，奥利维亚也了解你。谁来当严厉管教者，谁来当慈爱抚育者，这一点变得明朗了吗？
Oh, that's a good question. She's such a wonderful mother and so nurturing and also. Here it comes, here it comes. Well, I mean right now she's extremely nurturing, but she can be extremely organized. She has packing cubes. That was a good choice of words. Great choice.
哦，这是一个好问题。她是一位非常棒的母亲，那么充满关爱，而且。来了，来了。嗯，我的意思是现在她极其关爱他人，但她也能非常井井有条。她有收纳方块。这个词选得真好。太棒了。
Thanks guys. Now she can listen. So she's very good about organizing. Does that allow you to be... She's very organized, very disciplined in a way that I'm not. However, I don't know when it comes to Malcolm. The ideal I have for myself is that I come home in a suit, which is going to be hard working at home. And that there's some expectation of your dad is home and therefore that's intimidating, but I absolutely will never follow through on that.
谢谢你们。现在她可以听了。所以她很擅长整理。这能让你……她非常井井有条，在某种程度上比我更有纪律。然而，我不知道当面对马尔科姆时会怎样。我对自己的理想状态是，我穿着西装回家，尽管在家工作时这很难做到。并且某种程度上会有一种“你爸爸回家了”的期待，因此这会很有威严，但我绝对不会真正那样做。
My oldest brother, Dennis, when he has three kids, he would let them, with crayons, draw all over the walls in every room. And of course, that would upset his wife, and they would discuss it, and he was like, let him be kids, let him do anything they want. You can paint over the grants. Would you ever do anything like that?
我最大的哥哥丹尼斯，当他有三个孩子时，他会让他们用蜡笔在每个房间的墙上乱涂乱画。当然，这会惹恼他的妻子，他们会讨论这件事，而他的态度是，让他们做孩子吧，让他们随心所欲。墙面可以重新刷漆。你会做那样的事吗？
Well, here's the, and it should be noted also, he came from like Sean, Sean's dad never got mad at them drying on the walls or anything, and he didn't get mad at them doing anything. He would just what? Now the reason is he wasn't there, but... Well, if they hide the car keys, he'd hate that. That's the thing that would piss him off.
嗯，这里是，而且也应该注意到，他来自肖恩，肖恩的爸爸从来没有因为他们在墙上画画之类的而生过他们的气，而且他也从来没有因为他们做任何事情而生气。他只会……什么？原因是他当时不在那儿，但是……嗯，如果他们把车钥匙藏起来，他会恨透那样的。那是唯一会惹恼他的事。
Absolutely no chance of escaping would really piss him off. Who took my Toomey carry on? He was always mad. His dad left like... Who took my Weekender? His dad left like Cal El leaving Krypton, like just on his own, like in an escape pod. You know what I mean? I don't know if that's right.
绝对没有逃跑的机会真的会惹恼他。谁拿了我的托米随身行李？他总是很生气。他爸爸离开的时候……谁拿了我的周末旅行包？他爸爸离开的时候就像卡尔·艾尔离开氪星一样，就像他自己一个人，就像坐在逃生舱里。你知道我的意思吗？我不知道这是否对。
Yes, of course I got that. Well, Will and Jason, here's what I wonder. If I... I remember a good friend of mine when we were six, to his dad. He was so mad at his dad and he said, "'Sayonara, sucker motherfucker.'" And... And his dad acted mad.
是的，我当然听懂了。嗯，威尔和杰森，我一直在想一件事。如果我……我记得我六岁时，我一个好朋友对他的爸爸说过。他当时对爸爸气极了，然后他说：“‘再见，你这个蠢货操蛋货。’”然后……然后他爸爸表现得很生气。
And as I've gotten older, I'm like, I don't know how I won't laugh if my kid ever tells me off. It just will be... If Malcolm ever yells at me, it seems like such a funny moment that I won't be able to not laugh. Well we have, put it this way, I have videos of both my kids having, having breakdowns or tantrums at various ages because they're so fucking hilarious,
随着我年龄的增长，我觉得，如果我的孩子以后训斥我，我都不知道该怎么忍住不笑。这简直会……如果马尔科姆对我大吼大叫，这看起来会是个极好笑的时刻，我根本忍不住不笑。好吧，这么说吧，我有我两个孩子在不同年龄段崩溃或发脾气的视频，因为他们太他妈搞笑了，
which I show them now. And even in the moment, you recognize how funny, like Abel, we have one Abel saying when he was little and he was like, something, something, because you're the worst. And you can see him go in the moment go I mean not the worst I mean you're kind of great and I love you so he walks it back in the middle of his thing and then the other day when it Abel said to me that the other day went to wake him up for school I think I told
我现在给他们看这些。甚至在当时，你也能体会到有多搞笑，就像阿贝尔（Abel），我们有一个关于阿贝尔的例子，他小时候说过类似这样的话，因为你是最差劲的。然后你能看到他当时马上改口说，我的意思是不是最差劲的，我的意思是其实你挺棒的，我爱你。所以他在说话的过程中收回了之前的话。然后前几天，当阿贝尔对我说那件事的时候，前几天去叫他起床上学，我想我讲过
you guys this and I go up and he's he's 11 his eyes aren't even open yet and I go up and I go hey buddy buddy, we gotta get out, we gotta get to school. Eyes not even open and he goes, play is gonna play. I'm like what? They constantly surprise you, that's the thing. And you have no idea how you're gonna react and you just kinda go with it and I don't know.
你们知道吗，我走过去，他才11岁，眼睛甚至还没睁开呢，我走过去说，嘿，兄弟，兄弟，我们得出发了，得去学校了。眼睛都还没睁开，他就说，要玩，要玩。我说，什么？他们总是给你惊喜，这就是重点。你根本不知道自己会作何反应，只能顺其自然，我也不知道。
Speaking of not knowing how to react, hecklers, what's a good heckler story? Because you're on tour right now, right? Good for you, Sean. Thanks. From scratch, right? Back to the list. I emailed my bullet points to him.
说到不知道该如何反应，起哄者，有什么精彩的起哄故事吗？因为你现在正在巡演，对吧？真为你高兴，肖恩。谢谢。从零开始，对吧？回到名单上。我把我的要点通过电子邮件发给他了。
No, but I love those stories. I love heckler stories. The best, I was doing Bonnaroo one year and I was doing, there was a big comedy tent at the Bonnaroo Music Festival. I was doing, there was a big comedy tent at the Bonnaroo Music Festival in Murfreesboro, Tennessee. And someone said, we've signed you up to do a show at the VIP camping ground, like the organizers of the festival.
不，但我喜欢那些故事。我喜欢观众起哄的故事。最棒的一次，我有一年去参加博纳鲁音乐节，当时在穆尔freesboro，田纳西州，博纳鲁音乐节上有一个很大的喜剧帐篷。然后有人说，音乐节的组织者帮你在VIP露营地报名了一场演出。
And I said, what's that about? And they said, just get on the back of this golf cart. And they drove so fast in the back of a golf cart, which is like falling out of a chair forever. And they... I get to this... Like, I get to a plywood stage, and there's all these RVs,
然后我问，那是怎么回事？他们说，快上这辆高尔夫球车的后面。他们开着高尔夫球车在后面开得飞快，那种感觉就像是从椅子上永远地摔下去一样。然后我……我到了一个……就像，我到了一个夹板搭成的舞台，那里有各种房车，
and there's like a micro-brew truck giving out beer to these VIP glampers. Oh, you can handle, yeah. And they had no idea someone had been brought in to do stand-up. And they didn't ask for it, they didn't want it, they didn't like it. I was not someone they knew who that was. I was not someone people were excited to see. And I started doing stand-up and this guy yelled,
而且那里有一辆小型酿酒啤酒车，在向这些VIP豪华露营者分发啤酒。哦，你应付得来，是的。他们根本不知道有人被请来表演单口喜剧。他们没有要求，不想要，也不喜欢。我不是他们认识的人，也不是那种让大家兴奋得想见的人。当我开始表演单口喜剧时，这家伙大喊道，
I think I speak for everyone when I say we'd enjoy silence more than the sound of your voice. Oh my God. And it was so articulate. It was very polite. Yeah. How do you heckle back at that? I went, I went, hey, fuck you.
我想我可以代表大家说，比起你的声音，我们更喜欢安静。天哪。而且表达得非常清楚。非常有礼貌。是啊。这该怎么回嘴呢？我说，我说，嘿，去你的。
Fuck you. Sucker motherfucker. Yeah, sayonara, sucker motherfucker. Jump on the back of the golf cart, speed away. That actually would be a good... I might close a special with that. After a really gracious thank you to the audience, I turn around and then say, sayonara, sucker.
去你的。蠢货操蛋货。对，再见，蠢货操蛋货。跳上高尔夫球车的后座，加速逃离。那其实会是一个很好的……我可能会用那个来作一个专场的结尾。在向观众表达了非常诚挚的谢意之后，我转过身去，然后说，再见，蠢货。
It would be so great if that became your calling card farewell to your audience. Yeah, this aggressive, shitty little... I have this masochistic fantasy of doing one set of stand-up, but I would have no idea how to write a session. Have you ever heard of... We know. I mean, the very fact that you call it a session is not good. A session.
如果那成了你告别观众的标志性开场白，那就太棒了。是的，这种好斗、糟糕透顶的小……我有一种自虐式的幻想，想做一场单口喜剧，但我完全不知道该怎么写一个专场。你听说过……我们懂的。我的意思是，你竟然把它叫作“专场”，这本身就不太妙。一个专场。
But you know how like some... I'm here to perform a session. What are you playing? Guys, guys, listen up. I'm here to perform a session. Well you know like how some music acts, they don't write their own music but they perform them well. Have you ever heard of a stand-up having a whole set written for he or she and then they
但你知道有些……我是来表演一场的。你们在玩什么？伙计们，伙计们，听我说。我是来表演一场的。你知道有些音乐人，他们不自己写歌，但他们表演得很出色。你听说过有哪个单口喜剧演员的整场演出是别人为他或她写的，然后他们
do it? Yeah, I mean there are... and it's kind of more of an older school thing. Like, there were performers who had a lot of writers, and there were, you know, I really don't hear about it much anymore. There are people who do stand-up who also do so many other types of sessions that, acting sessions and directing sessions,
做吗？是的，我的意思是……这有点像老派的做法。就像，以前有些表演者有很多代笔人，而且，你知道的，我真的很少再听到这种事了。有些人做单口喜剧，同时也做很多其他类型的通告，比如表演通告和导演通告，
that they eventually have writers. But most people seem to... Why don't you go to an open session night? Are there? Yeah, go to open session. I'd actually like to end stand-up the way my therapist ends sessions, which is, okay, we have to pause now.
他们最终会有编剧。但大多数人似乎……你为什么不去参加开放麦之夜呢？有吗？对，去开放麦。实际上，我想以我的治疗师结束咨询的方式来结束单口喜剧，那就是，好吧，我们现在得暂停了。
And then just walk off stage. Jason, have you seen any good comedy routines lately? Would you like to go see some routines? You see some wonderful routines out there at the Improv, which is short for The Improvisation, they're on Melrose Avenue. I like when people call, like adults call, like my brother go, I'm doing a play here in Chicago, and he goes, you got play practice today?
然后直接走下台。杰森，你最近看过什么精彩的喜剧表演吗？你想去看一些表演吗？你在即兴喜剧俱乐部能看到一些精彩的表演，即兴喜剧俱乐部是The Improvisation的简称，他们在梅尔罗斯大道上。我喜欢人们这样称呼，比如成年人这样称呼，就像我哥哥说的那样，我在芝加哥有个话剧要演，然后他说，你今天有话剧排练吗？
Yeah. You mean rehearsal? Is this Dennis with the three kids? Yeah. Hey, I don't wanna bug you, I know you're in the middle of play practice today? Yeah. You mean rehearsal? Is this Dennis with the three kids? Yeah. Hey, I don't want to bug you. I know you're in the middle of play practice, but play practice. I know you're drilling the play. I do like saying practice instead of rehearsal when we're on set.
是啊。你是说排练？这是带着三个孩子的丹尼斯吗？是啊。嘿，我不想打扰你，我知道你今天正在排练剧本？是啊。你是说排练？这是带着三个孩子的丹尼斯吗？是啊。嘿，我不想打扰你。我知道你正在排练剧本，但排练剧本。我知道你在反复练习这个剧本。我们在片场时，我确实喜欢用“练习”而不是“排练”这个词。
That is fun. I do like yelling at a hockey game, shoot the ball. I do like that. Oh, man. Put that in your stand-up. Yeah. Oh, God, great idea. Yeah, you got a great start.
真有意思。我确实喜欢在曲棍球比赛里大喊大叫，把球射出去。我挺喜欢那样的。天哪。把它写进你的单口喜剧里吧。好啊。哦，天哪，好主意。对，你已经有了一个很好的开头。
John Mulaney, we've taken up way too much of your time. The tour is from scratch. Fuck, I know. Why is that? We could talk to Mulaney forever. I know, I don't wanna hold that. He's probably got shit to do. An encore, how about an encore?
约翰·木兰尼，我们已经占用了你太多时间了。巡演是从头开始的。他妈的，我知道。为什么会这样？我们可以和木兰尼聊个没完。我知道，我不想一直占着。他大概还有别的事要做。安可，来个安可怎么样？
We could just do another one where we follow up on everything we didn't finish. Which was everything. Every thread we start, just every little thread. We like to keep a million tabs open, you know? It's just, I know it's... This browser has a lot of tabs open. We're the worst. We're the worst interviewers.
我们可以再做一期节目，跟进一下我们没有完成的所有事情。也就是所有事情。我们开启的每一条线索，所有的小线索。你知道的，我们喜欢同时开着上百万个标签页？就是，我知道这……这个浏览器开了好多标签页。我们是最糟糕的。我们是最糟糕的采访者。
No, this was... You're the greatest. And I wouldn't want it any other way. You know, I mean, I think it was Vivek Murthy who said to you guys, I've had a great time. I've had a really good time on the show. You see the way he brought it all the way back around, you guys? This is what a pro does. That's how you end a session. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Thanks, John. Thanks, buddy. Bye, buddy. Bye, Johnny. Love you, buddy.
不，这真是……你太棒了。我不会有任何别的奢望。你知道，我的意思是，我想是维韦克·穆尔蒂对你们说过，我度过了一段美好的时光。我在这个节目里度过了一段非常美好的时光。你们看到他是怎么把话题完整地绕回来的吗，伙计们？这就是专业人士的做法。这才是结束节目录制的方式。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，谢谢谢谢谢。呵呵谢谢谢谢，这个字，真的谢谢各位哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！你听听。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！这绝对不是笑声。这其实是某种怪笑，而且还带着阴谋的味道，让人聽了心里发毛。不仅如此，紧接着又是一阵沉闷低沉的声音响起：“哼……”这声音仿佛来自地狱深渊，带着刺骨的寒意，令人毛骨悚然。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，那又怎么了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！这难道是……哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！你笑什么笑？
Thanks, John. Bye. John Mulaney, he's a smooth operator. So funny. Every time I see him on SNL, even in the sketches, I laugh out loud. Seems like a good guy. I've never met him before. You're right.
谢谢，约翰。再见。约翰·木兰尼，他真是个圆滑的角色。太搞笑了。每次我在周六夜现场看到他，即使在小品里，我也会放声大笑。看起来是个好人。我以前没见过他。你是对的。
He is. He's the shoddy of comedy. He's a smooth operator. Nice. That's great. Thank you, man. And doesn't stop. Like, he just keeps writing and writing and writing and doing stuff. I just don man. And doesn't stop, like he just keeps writing
他是。他是喜剧界粗制滥造的代表。他是个圆滑的操盘手。不错。太棒了。谢谢你，兄弟。而且永不停歇。就像他一直在写、写、写，一直在做事。我真是不行，兄弟。而且永不停歇，就像他一直在写一样
and writing and writing and doing stuff. I just don't, I'm so envious. Like I don't, first of all I can't write. I don't know how to write well. And then just to keep writing all that stuff that works all the time. All those Netflix specials, it's crazy. Yeah, it's a lot of stuff.
不停地写，不停地做事情。我真的是太羡慕了。首先我不会写作，我不知道怎么写得好。而且还要一直写出那些总能成功的作品。所有的那些网飞特辑，这太疯狂了。是的，东西确实很多。
And touring, doing touring and touring with stuff for a year or a year and a half and then doing a special. And then immediately, like, you got a sense of his work ethic. His show ends production, you know, this was years ago, and then next week he's out on tour and like, for a year. And then has a special like eight months later, like, what?
然后进行巡演，巡演了一年或者一年半，接着做了一场特辑。然后立刻，就像是，你能感受到他的职业道德。他的节目刚结束制作，你知道的，这都是几年前的事了，然后第二周他就开始巡演，大概持续了一年。接着大约八个月后又推出了一个特辑，真是不可思议。
And enjoys the hotels and the buses, like, it's not for me. I wonder how that's gonna go now with the kid. You know, like, is he gonna be able to be happy about being on the road all the time. Well, we know how that goes It changes it changes everything and you get like Yeah, you know, it's you better start working on that sitcom. It's hard. It's hard as you know The sitcom works for being a dad though, right? It sure does everyone Yeah, why doesn't everybody just do a sitcom, right?
而且喜欢酒店和巴士，这不适合我。我不知道现在有了孩子会怎么样。你知道的，他能适应总是在路上吗？嗯，我们知道结果如何。这改变了一切，你就会觉得，是的，你最好开始拍情景喜剧了。这很难，正如你所知，情景喜剧对当爸爸很有帮助，对吧？确实如此，大家都——是啊，为什么大家不都去拍情景喜剧呢，对吧？
Just do that for the first 10 years. I heard somebody, they're like, oh, I'm working this hard job, a friend of mine in New York works in this office, and my job is so hard, I'm like, why don't you just get a sitcom, and then you're at home all the time. Because you can just order those on Amazon, right?
在前十年里就这样做吧。我听到有人说，哦，我正在做这份辛苦的工作，我在纽约的一个朋友在办公室工作，我的工作太难了，我说，你为什么不直接去接个情景喜剧，然后你就能一直待在家里了。因为你可以在亚马逊上直接订购那些，对吧？
Just sign up for them. You're so stupid. Something such a stupid idiot can get a sitcom. But Mulaney is so, so hilarious. He's been so successful, and he just, you know, he is so, so, he's been so successful and he just, you know, he's one of those, he didn't sort of explode out of nowhere. He just kind of, he kind of built, he built, he built.
只要去报名就行了。你太蠢了。这么一个大笨蛋都能演情景喜剧。但木兰尼太搞笑了。他一直非常成功，而且他，你知道，他非常非常，他一直非常成功，而且他，你知道，他是那种人，他并不是那种突然爆红的人。他只是那种，他慢慢建立起来的，建立起来的，建立起来的。
Like Conan, like remember when Conan came on the scene and we were like, who the hell is this guy? He's got the talk show now? It's like, no, well if you look at his resume, like this guy has been a beast for a long time. But the SNL, the ones that Mulaney hosts, the SNLs that Mulaney hosts are always rated huge. Yeah, of course, which is why they keep bringing him back,
就像柯南一样，就像记得柯南刚出现的时候，我们都在想，这家伙到底是谁？他现在有自己的脱口秀了？就像是，不，如果你看看他的简历，这家伙一直是个猛人。但是SNL，由木兰尼主持的那些，木兰尼主持的SNL收视率总是极高。是的，当然，这也是他们一直请他回来的原因，
because he's hilarious and he always delivers. And so guess what, turns out that that works in show biz, Sean. Yeah, try being good, Sean. Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit, I just realized. Are we still recording? Yeah, I sell my headphones hands on I can hear you Sean Yeah, we didn't ask him his favorite color
因为他太搞笑了，而且总能给人惊喜。所以你猜怎么着，事实证明这在娱乐圈很吃香，肖恩。对啊，试着表现好一点吧，肖恩。哦，靠，靠，靠，靠，我刚想起来。我们还在录音吗？对，我把耳机摘下来了，我能听到你说话，肖恩。对哦，我们还没问他最喜欢什么颜色
Text shit who got an email address for me. Hang on. No, well, he did ask funny heckling story Yes, cuz I love that just a general That's up there with what's your craziest audition story? with what's your craziest audition story? But you know what it is I realized about Sean? Don't you love those stories? I love those stories. This is what I love about Sean. This is the reason that I like it.
This is the reason I like it. Okay. This is what. Okay, this is why. And I'm like, it's because Sean likes those things when stuff goes really wrong in normal situations. He loves people freaking out. Oh, he used to love bloopers and practical jokes, right?
这就是我喜欢它的原因。好吧。这就是什么。好吧，这就是为什么。我想说，这是因为肖恩在正常情况下事情变得非常糟糕时就喜欢那些东西。他喜欢人们抓狂。哦，他以前很喜欢出丑镜头和恶作剧，对吧？
And then those crazy home videos, right? Sean don't you miss it? You want to know what happened last Saturday late show at the play? Okay? Yeah, of course I shit you not it was this long. I'm doing my I've like seven monologues in the play in the middle of what I'm playing. There's two or three other actors on stage and I love you. Don't even know how many blanked out completely blanked out you did in the middle of one of my play, and there's two or three other actors on stage, and... I love that you don't even know how many. Blanked out, completely blanked out. You did? Yeah.
还有那些疯狂的家庭录像，对吧？肖恩，难道你不怀念吗？你想知道上周六深夜秀的话剧发生了什么吗？好吧？是的，当然，我没开玩笑，有这么长。我在演我的——我在剧中大约有七段独白，在我表演的正中间，舞台上有两三个其他演员，我爱你们。你甚至不知道有多少次大脑一片空白，完全一片空白。你在我的剧中间，舞台上有两三个其他演员……我真喜欢你甚至不知道有多少次。大脑一片空白，完全一片空白。你真的吗？是的。
In the middle of my thing I go, yeah, so I'm telling the story, blah, blah, blah, blah, and sold out, by the way. And I look at Ethan, and I'm looking at him, I'm like, fucking please help me. I know my mind went completely, I'm like, no idea where I am And then he says a line that
在我的部分中间我说，好吧，所以我正在讲故事，巴拉巴拉巴拉，而且顺便说一下，座无虚席。我看着伊森，我看着他，我心里想，他妈的求求你帮帮我。我知道我的脑子彻底卡壳了，我想，完全不知道我在哪里。然后他说了一句台词
Skips about a page and in my head I was like, thank you But I don't think I can skip that because there's information the audience needs in order to know the story later, right? so I was like No, it was that fucking awful. What about somebody in the wings? Anybody on book in the wings? I know, I said, and I said the stage manager, she goes, I almost came on the god mic and gave you your line.
跳过了大约一页的内容，我脑子里想的是，谢谢你。但我觉得我不能跳过那个，因为里面有观众为了解后面故事所需要的信息，对吧？所以我当时想，不，那真是糟透了。幕后有人吗？幕后有场记吗？我知道，我说，我跟舞台监督说，她说，我差点通过对讲机直接把台词报给你了。
I go, just do it, who gives a shit? I'm dying up there. But what about just kind of sauntering over to the wings in character to get a soda or something? They're in the back of the house. So what did you? So what happened? I fucking, I don't know, I somehow by a miracle.
我说，直接说吧，谁在乎呢？我在上面快尴尬死了。不过，那种保持着角色状态慢悠悠走到侧台去喝苏打水或者干点别的呢？他们在大剧场的后方。所以你当时怎么做？发生了什么？我他妈的，我不知道，我不知怎么地靠着奇迹...
Did the audience know, do you think? Yes, for sure. Really? A couple friends were like, hey, did you? And I was like, yeah. Oh yeah, did they ask for any portion of their money back? Like, could you ask for like five bucks back? Here's the scariest part, Sean, here's the scariest thing,
你觉得观众知道吗？知道，肯定的。真的吗？几个朋友问，嘿，你是不是……我当时说，对。哦，对，他们要求退还部分票钱了吗？比如，能不能要求退个五块钱什么的？最可怕的部分来了，肖恩，最可怕的事情是，
and Sean, we love you. I love you too. You told us this story verbatim yesterday. Yeah. Once you lay down and get your ankles above your heart, Sean. This is so fucked. We love you. We love you so fucking much.
肖恩，我们爱你。我也爱你。你昨天一字不差地给我们讲过这个故事了。是的。肖恩，快躺下把脚抬高过心脏。这太他妈离谱了。我们爱你。我们他妈的太爱你了。
We love you so fucking much. That's hysterical. Okay. Listen, by the way. Jason and Sean, just to bring it back full circle. I'm going to let you guys know, but I think that I have to go over to the store to check out the... The holes. The dressing rooms or the bathroom, because if for no other reason than... Here it comes.
我们他妈的太爱你了。太滑稽了。好吧。顺便听着。杰森和肖恩，为了圆回刚才的话题。我要告诉你们两个，但我觉得我得去店里看一下……那些洞。更衣室还是浴室，因为如果非要找个理由的话……来了。
I'm really... Buying Curious. There it is. for no other reason than I'm really... Bincurious! There it is. There we got it. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我真的是……买东西挺好奇的。来了。如果非要找个理由的话，我真的是……对大垃圾桶很好奇！来了。终于说出来了。SmartList由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机且手工匠心打造。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。